[Music]
all right say the name again go ahead
nick uh usk yeah say the first name I
don't even know his first name is it
alexand Alexander but with it's like
Alexander but with an O really oh yeah
what is this who is this a guy going to
fight Tyson Fury that was my line what
God I thought Franciso was fighting he
is he is doing that first this is what
the article's about tell him Anthony
tell me what a setup what a setup tell
me so he is fighting what end of the
month or something like that I think so
yeah but he also just signed a fight or
or basically announced he's going to
sign or some [__] like that Alexander
usk and that's going to be a [__]
record-breaking purse for Tyson Fury oh
how much and he's
retired it's all Saudi Arabian fight so
is that technically yeah but he's
fighting for a belt aren't they cuz usyk
is the other boxer right yeah he's like
the other heavyweight I I think he's
might be a division lower or just
different division heavyweight boxer
champ ion usyk is the guy and then Tyson
Fury is the other so it's like a
unification probably WB or W contract
has been signed um but not if he loses
oh is it exhibition with inano yeah it
it is exhibition with Ino what's the bag
they haven't officially said but right
now they know that it's going to be
over let's see PR it's going to be over
100 100 Mil they're
fighting do they not say the purses they
usually do in one fight damn to boxing
promoter Bob arum the purse for his two
bouts in Saudi Arabia uh including the
the first guy is a total of around $200
million wow [__] does everyone in Saudi
Arabia have lots of money yeah and they
love fights too I think they just
starting to move to sports I don't know
how true this is so fact check call me
[__] we don't do that here but I
hear I hear that whether it be 50 years
or 100 years or whatever there's a a
repeating process in Saudi where the
rich because right their government's
kind of run by the rich folk right
that's kind of the whole deal it's their
family that's a conspiracy theory but
it's the royal family so the family sits
down and sits down and talks about what
the next Investments or big things are
to come right and obviously probably 100
years ago is oil they made a bunch of
money whatever and then now it's if you
look at the Western world it's all
entertainment sport Etc and if you
exhibitions over the last 10 years all
their money's going to that right they
off like the golf yeah like the golf
started live like whatever 10 years ago
they tried to [__] get Li Messi for a
billion dollar to play one season they
and and it would have been a good
investment right you already look at
what he did here in America with his
like so their business planning as a
family is pure Sport and entertainment
right now wow cuz all the sponsorships
they get with every event they started
dumping into Esports recently they like
a huge VR thing going on so it kind of
makes sense VR what are they doing with
the VR dude there's some VR gam shout
out my boy uh Mike Chavez mik chav is uh
one of the best Halo players of all time
and now has his own Esports organization
I was on the call with him name is flame
sword I was on a call with him and he
they said there's this VR game that's
getting crazy competitive um it's one of
the ones where you actually like run
around you have like a like a fake gun
in your hand pretty freaking sweet he he
says it's it's basically legitimately
Call of Duty but you're moving but but
it takes an avatar your body so me and
Anthony could be on the same team and
there's different obstacles that you can
see over and I'm short and I can't and
your character in the game can like see
over and like your athletic movement if
I'm running 12 mph or whatever if I'm
capable of it my character can wow and
yours isn't cuz you run 10 m whatever in
a room or something yeah sometimes they
do treadmills and [__] 11 y 125 you know
power points but like it's legitimately
like turn into an eort wow so that means
it's it's real like a fact gamer that's
really crushing it on Halo or some [__]
yeah you're probably going to suck he
can't do but it might take like two
times the amount of bullets to knock you
down dude VR stuff is going to be so
crazy it's going to be nuts I would
wreck your friend at
Halo flame sword dog you heard him get
you heard him man cuz what I do what I
do what I do flame sword oh this is
going to make you piss stick him with a
plasma grenade you can't go anywhere
Mike Mike's face was on Red
Bull he's I'm just saying get good dude
can't get you can't stop plasma grenade
you put your face on there like
literally stuck to your body dud [__]
it's over you get a little icon every
time dude you get stuck that's true
plasma it's over but the VR shit's going
to be nuts you guys see that clip with
uh Lex Freeman and um Mark Zuckerberg
yeah the metal yeah and that's just the
metal one right I'm sure there's other
ones that are even better the clip what
happens in the clip well they they do a
facial recognition of obviously their
face and they put it in like a animation
through VR and it looks so Fu they do
like a VR Zoom call dude it's nuts it's
so crazy so I can only imagine what VR
look like G cuz I've seen like some of
the deep fakes and stuff that call is
what above that it's like 90% real
you're kind of looking like is that like
a picture how does AI know to make you
look better than what you actually do in
real life cuz AI is judging you they're
just judging [__] even fixing all Siri
says you're ugly you got some [__] up
cheekbones bro I'mma fix that a little
bit your ear I'mma smooth that out just
a little bit they're not trying to get
like the [__] pixelation of your acne
you know what I mean yeah I'm only doing
like Lightroom Photoshop V are they I'm
not going to The Meta they just change
[__] and I'm like why I don't look like
that little life hack too if you are
playing a third person game and you play
as a girl you get to stare at her ass
whole time yeah and then on top of that
if you're on the in the world they
people give you [__] nonstop it's like
the real world they don't stop giving
[__] you don't have enough room in your
inventory I think guys that choose
characters where it's like buff men and
you want to stare at them all day you
kind of gay dude when I play Saints role
when I when I choose characters it's all
always women in lingerie cuz we ain't
gay and then guys get horny and they
think that you're a girl all the time
and they're like can I quest with you
and I'm like sure so then you are kind
of gay so you're playing a girl to
attract a guy to make guy friends in the
internet who's leveling up faster me or
you your inventory is bigger how do we
[__] in the game can't [__] in the game
VR maybe how potting dude can't work
play Saints R and try to [__] me play
Saints R and try to [__] me I extend the
challeng exactly what can you do you can
teabag him while he's like on the ground
maybe that's it Saints roow is a game
about creating your own street gang mhm
rising from here it's just like the
beess GTA yeah it's really fun no it's
actually way more fun than GTA I never
played GTA cuz you could get a you never
played GTA what kind of gamer doesn't
never what are you [__] the first one
the airplane mode first one that should
have hooked you yeah I played that it
was cool but that didn't hook you n I
like the competitive [__] that's
competitive what do you mean it's that
comp online you never played online dude
it's most comp most competitive
environment that exists in gaming it's
like playing basketball at the park and
you play a pickup game with other people
there's missions like Apex and [__] you
know dude Apex nobody play Jo's a baller
so you should listen to them they are I
could obviously tell the gamer fumes are
hot on that table but I don't like you
bro we just don't like I can feel I can
feel the plasma grenade about to stick
you want to just call your friend play
yeah I do need flame on to protect me
but yeah I don't like GTA you probably
play Sims dude dress up a family full of
women what I do is I no what I do is I I
actually those are fighting words no I
put I put all I put a family in right
and I delete all the doors and I put
fireplace and I put all these wicker
chairs next to the fireplace and it sits
on fire roller coaster Coaster Tycoon
you are building the rest of the roller
coaster you're seeing all the
[__]
die a kid no I load the whole [__]
Park up with so much food places and I
have one bathroom and and then the
bathroom is like $500 to get in who
wants it more it's about who wants
it capitalism baby had its finest that's
so crazy you can do that in that game
yeah the game's literally from 97 guess
what guess what everyone's favorite ride
is by the way the [__]
bathroom they need it for
$500 so going back to the boxing match
we should probably talk about that a
little honestly we should think about
more Sims versions of the Worlds at
Steve creates cuz I think that's going
to be a movie he says he makes the Sim
world and then he will like throw an
apocalypse on him like like just a bunch
of natural events true story so my
brother I have a character in The Sims
when this is like I don't know Night
2000 year 2000 and and my guy's name is
Bruce Wayne and my brother my brother
yeah yeah thank you so my brother makes
a character and then my brother thought
it would be funny if he invited Bruce
Wayne over a bunch and then they got gay
together so then I get on my character
and I find out that I see Bruce Wayne
100% in love with my my brother Kenny's
guy I was like are you [__] kidding
me what did you do so then I decided you
know what well this will be pretty easy
I'll invite Kenny's character over to
have some fun with his new gay best
friend Bruce Wayne in the pool have a
little pool party and then when they're
both in the pool I deleted the ladder
and I hit fast forward and I just
watched them both
die I can they do that the S is Hardcore
you making they just drown in the water
they drown to
death yeah we played video games
differently got to climb out what's more
competitive than that this guy makes
Sims competitive yeah you drowned Batman
I drowned gay
Batman when he turned gay gay it his gay
boyfriend Batman's kind of gay though
cuz he got Robin yeah he going to get
and he has no girlfriend so Anthony Lee
do you think Tyson Fury is going to be
beat usyk
uh I don't give a [__] to be honest I
don't even know who usk is is he good
yeah he beat [__] uh who did he just
beat he beat uh one of those Russian
Brothers he beat the big Mexican dude
Ruiz oh Andy Ruiz be he dropped them or
he beat I think he beat Joshua he beat
Anthony Joshua I saw that yeah he beat
Anthony Joshua so he's like the he's the
big head honcho so there the two Titans
colliding for the these YouTubers
brought boxing back a little bit yeah
for sure absolutely bro too was whooping
on boxing's ass it was just a dying uh
both Sport and Spectators but then now
it's like repop and now they're making
fights boxing fights that people want to
see you know how long it would have
taken for them to do usyk versus Tyson
fury like a couple years ago well the
person was the same he probably would
have been down and that's true too but
then Jake Paul that [__] is
single-handedly changes the he really
might fight Canelo dude plus Mayweather
ruined boxing for so long cuz he's such
a technical fighter was so [__]
boring to watch it was that the Paul's
brought it back for sure no doubt oh
when's the [__] Dylan danis versus
Logan Paul fight oober
14th pull I thought Dylan pulled out I
heard it was a rumor dude they they
teased that fight at the wrong time they
milked it too long like I I was ready to
see that fight like two months ago I was
like hyped for it and now I don't give a
[__] I just want to see Logan Paul beat
his ass Dylan is still posting [__]
about his girl I kind of like danis too
kind of I saw him on a live stream I
think he's just playing the game you're
the anti well is kind of funny he's kind
of funny I'm team Logan got to ride for
my boy yeah but every day on Twitter
he's still posting his girl every
[__] day he still doing it I thought
he stopped doing it oh he's still doing
it cuz she she sued him I think well he
just did one today they go to court oh
really but gay Batman huh he's selling
that fight though who' he fight not
anymore